I let's see I'm going to talk to you
about human computation let me just
mention that this is joint work of
Jeremiah balakian Santos and Paula and
some of our students Lisa ma soeur ova
ela e lon Rosen Felton Samira samedi so
what human computation is about let's
see so it's about deciding which
algorithms are humanely computable this
means that they are computable by a
human working without the help of a
computer I don't know quite how to do
this working without the help of a cook
this means they are computable by a
human working without the help of a
computer and in a stated amount of time
seconds minutes an hour but that amount
of time is really important and for
algorithms that are humanely computable
it's about getting algorithmic upper
bounds and complexity theoretical or
balanced on the human running time the
usual sort of thing but I want to do it
for humans might be able to do the kinds
of algorithms i'll be talking about the
algorithms in this work have discrete
inputs typically strings of letters and
digits actions are described by the
usual operations of string processing
and integer arithmetic and my PhD
student former PhD student jeremiah
blocky his work involves algorithms that
in addition have visual and or auditory
inputs password creation so as a running
example of human computation I'm going
to look at the prototypical problem of
password creation and recreation there
are a bunch of problems that I could
choose but this is a nice one because we
are confronted with having to generate
passwords so password creation and
recreation creation refers to the first
time that a new password is generated
and Recreation refers to all later times
when generating that same password I
don't memorize any my passwords just
create one and I thats a method is used
the Jenner took recreate it whenever I
need it passwords will never memorize
recreated password schema is my name for
any human algorithm for creating and
recreating passwords by the way this is
ok 5 out of 40 see you can we're doing a
countdown here they're 40 slides all
together password schema + key so a
password schema together with a private
key I was used to map challenges to
passwords so a typical challenge you
know you go to a website what do you get
maybe it's amazon so you can read it
you're logging into amazon or ebay so
typical challenge is the name of the
website and the response to such a
challenge is a password so this is new I
have never seen anywhere in the
literature people talking about the
passwords are challenge response
algorithms there's a lot the
theoreticians can do here for example
here here's a schema which would take
ebay to lowercase a capital a one dollar
sign you know satisfying all the
requirements ebay except for the fact
that could be made a little longer by
having eBay eBay eBay it's this is
considered a good password it's a
terrible one of course because once you
see that the response to ebay you know
what the response to amazon will be
right so this is bad because the
adversary who sees one challenge
response pair knows how to respond to
all challenges okay so i have this
mnemonic for remembering what I'm doing
first picks sort of sounds like
toothpicks who speaks but the P so it's
an acronym for publishable humanly
usable secure password creation schema
and I'm especially interested in full
specs for what Google X calls the naked
person in the desert model of
computation no paper no pencil you don't
have anything you got to generate the
password this comes up more often than
you'd
real imagine suspects so P stands for
publishable and analyzable publishable
means everyone knows and can use the
same schema I'll tell you a schema you
can all use it in particular the
adversary knows the schema oh the
adversary knows how what you're doing to
what makes one person's password
different from another's is that the
schema makes use of a secret private key
and each person has a different key
analyzable means the description is
sufficiently precise to enable the
Turing machine without access to the web
that's really what a true machine is no
access to it to transform challenge to
password and then let me just make a
point about this that publishable and
analyzable seem related but they're
different you can have either one
without the other most people don't
publish their schemas though those that
are published are unanalyzable because
they're not precise enough you know take
a sentence and use the first letter of
every word it's a wonderful way to
choose your password they don't tell you
how to choose that sentence and how do
you remember the sentence so okay so
first pics so password this is important
because not it's true not just for
password algorithms for many others
these algorithms have two parts to them
pre-processing loops for memorizing the
password schema and for generating and
memorizing private key pre-processing
that's the work you have to do in
advance if you want to use the schema
you've got to learn what the schemas
you've got to generate and memorize a
key and that may take a while processing
for generating passwords you don't want
that to take very long I wouldn't mind
taking up to an hour for preprocessing
but if you're going to generate a
password you want to be able to do it in
30 seconds it should go fast humanly
usable means pre-processing time time
for initial long-term memorization
should take at most two hours preferably
just half an hour this includes the time
for rehearsals over the users lifetime
paper-and-pencil okay for this
so I would love that actually you want
to use paper and pencil because you're
going to create a key for yourself and
you want to be able to remember that key
so the Nightside wood on paper for a
while processing time to take at most a
minute preferably 30 seconds and you
should do it without paper and pencil
totally in your head secure means that
an adversary who has seen a few randomly
chosen challenge-response pairs has low
probability to generate the users
password for a new site that's what I
want and the password game which I'm not
about to makes this whole notion precise
you're okay with a yes I'm okay with
point 1 probability it's we can talk
about hi yeah we can talk about that so
it's interesting you see a lot of a lot
of a lot of people especially in this
room will be interested in the security
my real interest is in the human
usability oh you'll see some of these
things you'll have a chance to see why i
am i'm okay with Oh point one okay
anyway I won't get into the password
game I just want to make a point here
randomly chosen challenge-response pairs
but basically you shouldn't tell people
your password just telling you don't
tell give away more than six passwords
so and dunk it dunk about my passwords
okay passwords creation schema is a set
of instructions for a human to transform
challenges into passwords that point one
can be changed we would point 0 1 would
that be better
for you are you you in the end the S or
you want okay the use of schema has many
interesting properties you don't have to
remember your passwords you just have to
remember the public schema and the
associated private key schemas and keys
are easy to remember you use them every
time you need a password they're self
reversible that's the nice thing if you
use the schema every time you went you
know when the Machine tells you do you
want me to remember the password for you
you should always say no otherwise
you're going to forget your password you
use the opportunity to reconstruct your
passwords then the schemas and the keys
are self reversible the use of a schema
and kia commonly visited sites rehearses
their use at other sites the use of
schemas as many interesting properties
one nice thing is you don't need to test
any actual passwords you can test the
schema together with your private key on
bogus websites and challenges we don't
have to give them anybody you're not
tell googled your actual password just
make up a challenge and get a password
and then well my favorite test is this
you know you know there are all these
password checkers that you can they're
lousy all of them they're lousy mine my
favorite one is this take the schema use
the scheming key to produce a password
and then see if Google recognizes it
Google doesn't recognize that you're in
good st. you're in good shape
that's I haven't seen anybody mentioned
that either but that that's the way I do
it so the use of schemas as many
interesting properties challenges or
website names these names are given to
you by the site you want to log into if
you modify the website name for example
by going from an American Express to
amex the transform challenge is
surprisingly easy to remember you'll
remember that you use amex nearly
effortless not at all like remembering a
weird string of symbols and if you write
down the challenges in your iphone to
ever I I don't anymore even write down
the challenges of my iphone but I used
to write passwords that's terrible
somebody get your iphone they got your
passwords now I for a while I was
writing down the challenges but I found
that I can always remember them so I
haven't even done that you write down
the challenges in your iphone and
thieves get your iphone they don't get
your password they get something else
the use of schemas so the last of these
I don't have to remember even if I have
a password so last month Lenore asked me
my password for rei I could honestly
tell her I don't know if I'm even
registered a tour guide but if I am
here's my password and later she cool
down yet you're registered this happens
mmm at least once a month roof data
schema is usable by at least one human
so let me just mention that I've given
the talks different kinds of talks one
of them was to Andrew sleep a program
that Stephen brutish set up for bright
high school students and I asked for
challenges basically come up with a
challenge challenge is any word that I
can spell you know that could possibly
be a website name take that challenge I
and I turn it into a password students
got the seat oops how long it takes me
to generate a password which is about
three seconds four digit half a minute /
password I have to volunteer to use my
Python program see this since its
analyzable i can write a program for
doing this that's a volunteer to use my
Python program to check my responses to
assure them that first of all I'm not
cheating and because I occasionally do
make mistakes so okay so and here's what
happened this summer one there were
several different students making
suggestions and one of them was very
clever and said brain train grain train
see he's trying to figure out what what
I'm doing and then somebody else gave me
magic and so what I did is I actually
gave him the response to magic one magic
to magic three magic for etc you can
this this is useful like if you can if
you need to change your password you
just change the digit at the end you see
you see anything but that's going on
here
I'll give you a chance to to [ __ ] this
is going to be an IQ test I'm going to
put this back up and ask you to figure
out what's going on ok so today it's so
so so one of the things i could do is
just show you how to generate passwords
one possibility but i thought that what
i would do here with you is i want to
show you that you personally can use a
schema to create passwords ok and what
i'm going to do is I'm going to request
to volunteers actually for would be even
better I'm going to whisper in their
ears how to do it and then one of two of
them are going to stand over there and
two of them will stand here and they
will take your challenges and you'll see
how they produce the passwords and of
course that will be an IQ test two
you're going to have to figure out what
the heck they're doing ok so while i'm
getting my volunteer this is for those
of you who want and you can try to see
what's going on I need four volunteers
come on up come on come on for volunteer
please please please yes thank you too
will do but how about two more please
please please yes come up ok so I'm
going to listen to me also so you're
going to 24 here 24 there actually why
don't you all come over here for a
second while I xsplit whisper in your
ears
you
so you're going to have to do this
you're going to write the challenge and
then the the password after it okay i
need a challenge get a a word short word
let's let's start them off easy oh oh
good home let's see what you do hom e oh
yeah yeah you don't look at each other
you I'm I am I gotta tell show the
audience that you're not into hoots
don't look yeah don't look don't look
just look at the board
the first time doing it but they start
off
it helps to have a little practice I see
them covering up there
we're done okay they agree thank you
thank you thank you thank you anybody
shoot anything going on here it's the
fermentation of the post-cold it's very
good that's the only thing anybody has
ever seen is it notice this first column
is a permutation how about the second
column third column permutations last
one it's not part of the part of this is
just because if it wasn't a permutation
well it doesn't matter I won't get into
the permutation is purpose this is is
there on purpose ok so today I prove to
you you can do it now proof that you
personally can use a schema next I'll
tell you how to do this for yourself so
what I told them I'm going to tell you a
good way to do this what I tell you
won't help you break the scheming keys
by the way that I gave them I have lots
of schemas but if 11 good ones going
always needed so before I do this yeah
okay we've been through this so here's a
way to transform challenges into
passwords okay and I hope you give it a
try generate and memorize a map from
letters two words you know in the Army
we learned something was what what was
it was Adam Baker Charlie David company
that though there were words for every
single one of the letters so it's not
it's not impossibly difficult but don't
use one of the known
words per letter so make the the right
way to do this is simply to pick from 10
words that begin with a trickle pick 10
I like names 10 names that begin with a
I got rg10 names that begin with be they
have lots of names begin all the letters
except X and Q bren to take a word that
begins with C Charles respond to a
challenge by replacing each letter in
the challenge by the the letter after it
in the word so C is Charles that's the H
comes over here then a is the letter
after a is our and then the letter F to
be is our that would be the response
this this particular schema has quality
6.5 what that means is that if you for
most dictionaries including the top 40
websites which could sample set an
adversary who gets less than 7 passage
challenge-response payers will not have
enough information to be able to figure
out what's going on but if they have
seven and they have a reasonable chance
to find out what's going on in computer
LOL you could computer i think i just
sampled it you just you take the first
40 websites you try ordering in all
possible ways on the average the top 40
but if for any dictionary just take a
sample I didn't tell you the game that I
used to determine the queue so but
basically I guess the basic thing is
what what I'm promising you just this
don't give away more than six passwords
but you're okay until then if you want
an even better method then you slightly
bigger words like Archibald instead of
Archie and Brendan's that our brand and
Charlamagne instead of Charles and then
respond to a challenge by
placing the ice letter and challenged by
the I plus first letter in the key so
you see the the first a gets turned into
a little are the next day gets turned
into little see the next day gets run
into little H and the B gets turned into
D so you always I use my fingers one two
three four five you keep track of which
letter you're on and then you pick out
the corresponding letter put it in this
has quality 20.5 so you can give away a
lot more but the truth is why would you
give away anything why would you give
anybody your past well I give a little
more my passwords why would you give
away your challenge this you can give
away passwords just don't give away the
challenge response pair if you're going
to use ebay well you could use ee BBU ay
ayy you could use this you know you
could use exb y AZ you don't have to
give away your challenge the method you
use to create the challenge from the
website that can be your own method and
nobody else need to know about it so oh
you thought you don't have to give away
20 I think this is much more complicated
than is necessary but you can have it
see this is the best by the way that
we've been able to get the best highest
quality that we've been able to get so
security of the schema security of all
the schemas are based on information
theoretic arguments so as long as you
don't give away more than few
challenge-response pairs you can expect
to be secure what are there are some
statistical things of like people choose
like a Charlie for see a lot oh yeah so
that's why it's really important for for
you to start off with taking for four
words that begin with C and then picking
at random one of them try to choose to
you know you don't want Charles want
Charles to you don't want Charlie chart
and charlie c mode you know you want it
you want to have words where that that
letter after c is different in each case
and now pick at random then you're fine
that's a very good question
okay so about human computability so
different humans are like different
models of computer some are slower some
faster we count the steps that human
takes
because the steps of human takes some
humans add two digits mod 10 twice as
fast as others that's no different than
that some computers run at twice the
speed of others so now I'm okay human
computability a human calculator so much
slower than a computer that any proof
that a computer cannot break a password
schema must generally be information
theoretic complexity theoretic proofs
are almost certainly not relevant and to
see why consider that the the world
record for multiplying two randomly
chosen eight digit crimes in one's head
is currently three and a half minutes
Freddy Hernandez six februari 2015 not
that long ago there there championships
on this this considerably three and a
half minutes it's a lot more time than
is acceptable for generating a password
and yet Wolfram Alpha can factor the
resulting product in the fraction of a
second so the point is that complexity
theory is not about what's coming in
here it's information theoretic maybe
not what about human computability let
me mention the data structures of the
brain I don't know to what extent you
may have thought about the fact that you
know the data structures we did you
think about when you think about
memorizing the alphabet did you think
about how you're going to store it in
your brain what data structure do you
use well I tell you you all use singly
linked list abcdefg you can go backwards
but you have to learn a different a
different singsong for it c YX WBU TS r
QP oh and then lkj is GFE dcba so you
can do that but you know even having
gotten now this ability to go forward
and backward I still can't when given P
tell you what comes before and after
that would be like random access and I
don't have that in my head that's the
next job I need to do okay
algorithms for human computation
requires spelling out details that we
normally pay little attention to these
include how data is stored in the brain
for example most of us can recite the
alphabet in the forward direction few of
us can recite it backwards the alphabet
appears to be stored in our brain
there's a singly linked list with few
with a few pointers into it so if I ask
you what comes before p what comes
before p oh that's good that's good most
people have to go back maybe l m n o p
oh thank you that's good we were you
looking no okay okay it takes more work
to store the alphabet as a doubly linked
list in which the letters before and
after any given letter such as Ella
recalled in one step and so telling
people how to store stuff in the brain
it's important for some of these schemas
some of them you really want to be able
to tell them what they need to know so
they can do this quickly about human
computability algorithms for humans must
specify if the human is required to do
the computation in their head or paper
and pencil is allowed yeah I want it to
be done in your head here here the head
home to look at but I really want it in
the head in the case of passwords paper
and pencil are ok for the pre-processing
you know for the memorization stage but
not ok for the processing generating the
password about human computability when
we say that a human can do a certain
computation in one minute this is
because steps have been counted and the
reasonable running time per step has
been assumed or asserted so this is an
important part of it that we can do for
human computation what we do for our
ordinary computer work you know when we
write an algorithm we can count the
number of steps should do the same thing
for what people are doing one difference
is that constants are important you know
recognizing that a computation is linear
order n is useful but it's not enough
the specific constants are actually
important in this
in this business another about us so
there's this CSPs constraint
satisfaction problem solvers you know
like SAT solvers they're actually quite
powerful in our experience if a
published password scheme can be broken
and they say here what it means to be
broken then a CSP solver will break it
just needs to be given enough challenge
response pairs that's why
information-theoretic is really
important you want to make sure that the
information isn't gotten there so a
password schema is broken if an
adversary who knows the schema but not
the key and have seen the response to
seven randomly chosen challenges has a
good chance to guess the response and
that's what it means to be broken here's
a conjecture about passwords I don't
know I don't know I want this to be true
or I wanted to be false I just would
like to have the answer I don't even
know I don't know here's what it is I
don't know if a human being can do
something in their head you know can can
actually create passwords you following
a schema that I don't know if a human
being can compute a hash function in
their head that say a one-way function
compute a hash function that somebody's
who sees the output can't figure out
somebody with a computer who is easy out
but can't figure figure out what came
before so here's a precise passwords
conjecture if in time t1 a human can
both learn a humanly usable schema s and
also generate and memorize or private
key for us that's because you need both
right you need the scheme and you need
the key to be able to get passwords take
you a certain amount of time to memorize
that that's time t1 if he I used he
because the users are he in my
terminology and the adversary is she so
they both come up if he can then use s
okay to transform a random set of n
challenges into corresponding
sponsors and responses in his head in
expected time t2n so of course then that
should t that the t2 should be
relatively small I want less than a
minute per / password then a computer
program typically a modern constraint
satisfaction problem solving problem
solver running on the laptop on input
given the schema and these challenge
response pairs will find the key or an
equivalent key one that generates the
same responses to the same challenges in
the same total expected amount of time
or less d constant simple i'm not even
putting in twice that amount of time
it's not even a constant I'm telling you
that I that the conjecture is saying
that you can't come up with a scheme
abbr yeah so the conjecture I'm not sure
about this I could have stated as an
open problem I'm stating as a conjecture
that any schema you can come up with
it's possible to have a program break it
in that same amount of time any
questions about that you're measuring
time in units of time rather than steps
yeah yeah so my whole goal in this thing
is when you have a schema you cut you
you you count the number of steps you do
that but each of the steps is small like
add this add 3 plus 7 mod 10 @ 9 + 6 mar
tendence they're very small steps and
each one it's easy to check how long it
takes to do them and then from that you
get seconds it takes a human five
minutes then we'll take a computer at
those five minutes right my laptop okay
human usability model so this is perhaps
the most interesting part you have time
yeah so the most interesting parts is
just usability so I I as a graduate
student I had a wonderful mentor named
Warren as McCulloch he was a
neurophysiologist and we were interested
in the brain and I wondered what's a
good model for the brain is it a finite
automata is it a Turing machine or is it
something in between what's what's the
model and I was wondering about what
might be the right model finite automata
seems wrong because that would mean that
if you know German it's because you use
built-in that's sort of Plato's our
notion of our brain it's not that's
something wrong there here here's the
model a human is a finite state machine
alright but with access to a long-term
relatively permanent memory and the
short-term working memory actually this
is all this is telling us that this is a
bit of computer science that maybe it's
connected to cognitive science what
you'll see here is that the cognitive
scientists know things that are useful
for this human computation long term but
this model is mine it's a long-term
relatively permanent memory what's
relatively permanent memory mean it's
very interesting there's a guy named
Wozniak not the computer was neck it's a
different wozniacki SI polish
psychologist who
who said well if it took if you remember
today something that you remembered
yesterday 24 hours ago then very likely
you'll remember it tomorrow 24 hours
later and in fact it's a good chance
you'll learn it remember it 48 hours
later so write it remember today
something you remembered yesterday then
two days later you might still remember
it and then if you remember it then then
four days after that you might remember
it and then eight days after that you
might remember it so he based so washing
act basically said that there is a
doubling schedule which he recommends
for memorizing stuff and he spent his
whole life actually working with this
one of the many wonderful experiments he
has is he took seven computer science
students in colon just by chance that
happens to be computer science 7
computer science students who wanted to
polish who wanted to learn English in
the process in the next few years what
he what he what they did is they built
up a vocabulary of 40,000 words I got
40,000 words that's bigger vocabulary
than I have and he did it in order to
find out what this doubling schedule
what the scheduling is he found that in
every case if you remember something
from a day from a month ago that you
need to rehearse it two months later one
you don't have to rehearse it a month
later two months later we'll do but not
too much more and he found the constant
the constant was not always to it was
between 1.8 and 2.3 on these seven
students Harry cooks very close and he's
been doing this for very very many years
in his life so he keeps careful that
tabs he has written programs which
basically they wake you up and tell you
what to what to rehearse so that you can
check it out ok
sure give me just known 40,000 miles
they didn't say anything about that you
just said that 40,000 words that's also
in the word says they're not as bad as
you they were kind of finding Scrabble
but they're not the obvious words either
and in any case they did not start out
with knowing very much English only
words didn't tell them how to you okay
long-term memory which storm which
stores schemin key is written in the
pre-processing stage refreshed to use
and used in the processing stage in
read-only mode so basically the model is
long-term memory which which takes a
while to get stuff into it and then when
you need to use it you you are using it
in read-only mode it's unblock term
memory is unbounded and people think
it's fine then no no I'm think it's
infinite except for the substantial time
and effort needed to acquire it a
concentrated hour or so for an
acceptable password scheme and key right
you're going to learn those maps from
letters two words it'll take you an hour
the relatively small time and effort and
speed rehearsals required to maintain it
measured in minutes over a lifetime and
the length of one's mentally healthy
life of course is this is not infinite
because at certain point you stop stops
working you brain stops working well at
that point you're not interested in
using passwords anyway so it doesn't
matter short-term working memory
short-term memory is a tiny read/write
memory why it's so small I don't know
but tiny means seven plus or minus two
chunks you've heard about this that we
we can store and I had seven plus or
minus two chunks what's a chunk chunk
can be so if you read the literature
chunk could be a letter digit a word I
can tell you what it is a chunk is a
pointer really it's a pointer you store
in that short term memory a pointer to
some item in long-term memory that's
what a chunk is its appointed to some
in long-term memory and what you might
be doing and ok so for prayer the chunk
are being appointed to a well-defined
item in memory and that item could be a
digit a letter a word the entire
alphabet and so on short term memory is
a tiny readwrite memory for purposes of
the password problem it is used in the
processing stage to transform challenge
to response and if you're there trying
to transform challenge response you are
very aware of the fact that you can only
store so much in your head it's a basic
fundamental limit their short-term
memory severely bounded seven plus or
minus two chunks and password
computations that typically consists of
two characters two letters two digits or
one letter in one digit and a pointer
into one or at most two sequences these
being typically the challenge itself and
at most one additional sequence the
people who were doing this up on the
board they had a pointer into a
telephone number and a pointer to the
word that those are the words or what
they needed ok they needed a pointer
into the alphabet short-term memory
fades quickly items and short-term
memories that are needed but not
recalled for more than two or three
operations must be reconstructed
okay so and then here's see six out of
seven look 34 out of 40 we're getting
there okay come short term working
memory for letters and digits is a stack
of two elements accessing an entry
whether top or bottom has certain costs
retrieving a sequence as a certain cost
here I'm telling talking about the kinds
of operations that you can perform in
your head and the cost like you have
appointed to some letter in the alphabet
what's the next letter boom that's
course one step provided of course
you've got the alphabet in your head
wasn't always clear that they did have
the alphabet ahead but anyway moving the
pointer one step to the right has cost
one resetting the pointer into a
sequence we sitting if that you have a
challenge resetting the pointer to the
start of the challenge once that we're
setting it to the end of the challenge
one step moving forward one step moving
backward that's very hard for us to do
so they're complexities of kinds of
operations we can do in our head with
arithmetic operations you can do
arithmetic mod 10 in your head even Mart
11 is kind of nice mod seven is I don't
know if you can do it mark seven you can
do operations of plus minus x in your
head and you can write down what they
cost and so you write down these
operations and you find out how much it
costs to do them and that gives you a
very nice way to say how long it will
take to perform a schema and then you
can see if your schema really satisfies
the condition that it will take at most
one minute preferably 30 seconds to
produce a password this is worked very
nicely
ok
so I won't go through this other
problems lots of other problems to
consider so the password problem as i
said is prototypical but can a human do
coin flipping over the phone me against
you know the usual Bob and Alice meeting
Bob against Alice Bob you're supposed to
do in your head but Alice maybe as a
computer and this cheating is it
possible to do coin flipping in your
head even against the cheeping cheating
adversary I've had suggestions for what
might work but in each case they're not
really humanly usable the answer could
conceivably be yes but I don't know zero
knowledge is a fascinating concept right
an idea that you can convince someone
that you know a secret without giving
away that secret with zero knowledge
proof you can in principle convince a
bank that you know your password without
giving it away anyone can hear your
conversation of the bank the
conversation in which you convince the
bank you know your password but no one
can impersonate you and that even the
bank wouldn't it be wonderful to be able
to do zero knowledge proofs in your head
but I don't I don't believe it can be
done and here I'm giving why I mean I
don't think a human being can can
compute a one-way function it's sort of
very much like a human being and
multiplied two numbers in their head but
the numbers you can multiply in your
head can be easily factored I don't
believe a human so I don't I think zero
knowledge proofs are out of scope but
again I don't have proofs anyway that's
what human computation is about and
that's it
three questions at least please yes how
very high ability is possible so like
the problem we just did up there with
the house would like without knowing
that has written schema how can a
computer verified yeah not great well
first of all what I told you in your
year I could certainly write a program
for it but what you tell the bank you
know what you tell chase bank is the is
the password you don't tell them that
you're using chase or any modification
of chase as your challenge you just tell
them the password they get just the
password they certainly don't find out
what your key is you don't tell them the
schema or the key although the bank
could is this were used by a lot of
people the bank would know a schema
you're using another question that's a
very good one though I've got many but
it's taken me years to come to realize
that this is one of the best mind
transforms like magic one you give me if
you want to you can you ask me what
magic three years and we can go back
you'll see I'll generate it you can give
me chained rain you can hold at 24 26 26
but the point okay so this is a good
point the point is that first of all
people do learn it because all these
radio operators know these words so
certainly can't be too hard and then
secondly there is a magician named Juan
comedies he's Italian oh thank you so
yeah Italian in Manuel and he's
wonderful because you know when he
talked since with his hands and he's a
magician and he will teach you how to
memorize the random order of the the
order of a random that you take a deck
of cards 52 cards and you you know you
what are they doing shuffle them shuffle
them you get random order and then he
will teach you how to memorize that
random order he guarantees you will
memorize it and remember it permanently
in three hours and it's very interesting
because Noah doesn't go by that doubling
schedule he's telling you at the end of
three hours you will know that order and
if you wakes you up in the middle of
night and asks you what's where's the
queen of hearts you know there's a
wonderful video to see so the point is a
magician can do this with three
concentrated hours of course I want to
do with much less I would like just one
minute I mean Lenore is unwilling my
wife is unwilling to learn anything in
order to use the schema so that that's
why I needed to have something I could
whisper in their ears Russell like
totally different domains other than
security one thing where you could apply
like thinking about human abilities to
compute one thing that comes to mind is
like emergency response there's the loss
of like mnemonics people use to decide
what to do in certain emergency
situations can you like optimize use
this ideas to optimize these mnemonics
or come up your what's up well what's
what give me an example i live by
examples like so i never learned any of
these things
an example like drop roll and something
or other there's a fire I seen don't use
the elevator you would like to have it
burned into your brain firing building
and you're like the you're the fighter
manager for the ability you have a
checklist of things you're supposed to
follow you know how complicated that can
that reckless be can you have digital
this again is getting into the cognitive
science so let me tell you that first of
all there are some wonderful things that
are known I mentioned one here the
doubling schedule I mentioned another
one tamaris this thing what I didn't
mention to you is Joshua forwards book
do you know Joshua forward book if you
haven't read this thing you gotta read
it it's wonderful bedtime reading Joshua
forward he's a he's a journalist he was
assigned to go to New York to there is a
memory comp contest being held in New
York he's supposed to write about it he
went there new constitutes these guys
that were there they were crazy we're
crazy they they came with attache cases
you know what's in the attache case 12
decks of cards why because part of the
memory contest is you shuffle these
decks of cards and then you see how many
of them you can remember if the the
world championship for memorizing the
order of a deck of cards 45 seconds but
these are not world champion so it takes
them a minute can you imagine you go
through the card
in one minute they know that then they
go on to the next deck of cards how can
you do this so this is you can read in
the joshua forest book it's called
moonwalking with moonwalking with
Einstein and it's great by the way let
me just mention them when he saw these
guys doing these crazy things he asked
them first of all g have aren't you have
you ever been worried about the fact
that maybe somebody was a one of these
fantastic memories what's the what's it
called these photographic memories would
come and blow you out of the water so we
used to worry about it we're sure that
such things don't exist these people
have simply learned how to do this
they're all normal people so normal
people that you mean I could learn to do
this I could be the memory champion you
sold yes if you follow my instructions
spend real concentrated time in one year
you can be the memory champion so he
took him up on it worked on it for one
year the next year he was the us memory
champion which is not as good as the
European memory champion don't pretty
good that's great bedtime reading if you
want to answer your question Russell
that's the book to read going back to
the issue of the one-way function I want
a little work of the upper body shine we
should have its minimizing
we continue to add about could it be
brought down to a two level between us
can perform yeah so and now this is a
good point I'll mentioned something that
I have thought about so are from
suggested for for this sort of thing
that one way to do coin flipping over
the phone is you take the fault user
following one wave function you take a
hundred digits under they just memorize
location of ten of them you can put a
hundred digits into a picture you can't
put very much more and you can't
remember what the locations except you
can remember it's the ear the nose
everybody picks on those the left
shoulder is a belly button you can
remember different parts you they these
cartoons you put in these digits you can
remember ten locations okay and then
what you do is you some those ten
locations moet you can do that that
should be your your the function you
compute yeah you want more than one
digit so you do this 10 times to get 10
digits okay so this has a nice property
it's in general n digits square root of
n is what you memorize nobody knows how
to what we know you know Gaussian if you
have n equations you can solve but with
less equations it can be impossible to
solve it's all you have to do is be able
to remember the square root of n
locations and add them quickly I don't
know how to do that I don't it's very
hard for a human being to actually do
this 10 times you know to do this
edition mar 10 and then do it again and
again and do it 10 times your way over a
minute by then so I don't know even for
something as seemingly possible as coin
flipping weather really is possible this
was a great suggestion but
of course some people say that humans so
much move year for solving problems
present it isn't differ across problems
then yes well so Jared and Jeremiah
blocky who I mentioned it and you know
worked on this with me has looked at the
whole problem of using visual memory the
problem is usually I don't know how to
make good use of it you know we learn
how to ride a bicycle we don't know how
we ride a bicycle this is something that
we can learn but you know it's very
funny most people think that when you're
in a bicycle if you want to turn right
you should turn right no you turn left
and fall to the right that's what gets
you going to the right people don't know
what it is they do in that case but I
don't know how do you make use of that
to actually produce passwords I would
love to one example would be great well
you've been very patient thank you very
much